[Music]
recently there were 1,300 pounds of
ancient Roman coins found inside old
pots treasure yeah that's [ __ ] tight
I know
anyway 300 pounds worth of coins yep
That's not me oh my god it was record it
was the bringer of dinner reminder 17
you always tell us to keep it on
airplane silence she says airplane walks
before every take well she didn't say it
this and we and you know what I didn't
do anything old [ __ ] I was in the middle
of a text conversation and I put myself
on airplane yeah do use Vaseline
why not chapstick cuz I like the buzzing
last longer feel really airplane mode do
it nah not for me all right
I cannot believe my phone was not an
airplane I hope the audio was okay can
you tell me more about this treasure
yeah go to Rome one I've been there huh
huh
1,300 pounds of ancient Roman coins
found in Spain because the Roman Empire
stretched out to the Spanish oh my god
you didn't know then you know these
words it was a rhetorical question
Thank You Bart delivery is everything
Gio did you even hear the way I said it
you never have my phone oh is that your
back how is every bad he always has your
back always had my back
he always has your back who's just
trying to teach you something he always
had your back ways he had your back he
was like oh maybe she doesn't know about
your bag I feel like I've seen your
naked bag that's how many times we've
all seen it
he's a spider so well don't be mad he'll
bleed he has her back so much that now
he's your neck brace
yeah no one back to your back to his
back I'm your [ __ ] chair he's always
shirtless we all right you guys you guys
deescalate in it all right thank you see
I got your back right
yes elated jeez your backpack we're good
we're good
can you carry bar yeah Oh actually
that's wrong that's like a turtle shell
on your back doctor please fun I carry
the relationship or it's like 300 and
300 pounds of plod on your back okay
it's hidden treasure that's pounds yeah
or 1300 oh no no not this so there was
like it was where was that big pots yes
so yeah they was found the coins were in
the pots there were 19 pots so they it
looks like they just made it for the
coins yeah it's not meant to it's el
chapo
its roll man el chapo that was hiding
money back in the Roman times they had a
whole bunch of pots like this and stuff
understand this was all they had a thing
that would like you put it in the thing
it was Alexander the I he hated these
because they look just like the yam the
only reason why he knows because I went
to this museum and then they were
talking about how back in the day they
had that in Croatia and I was like I
wanna go crazy
they look like turnips they do give you
some more you went to the Balkans that
it's around that area
you think yes you go to Miami no that's
in Burma ii ii see if you're full of
[ __ ] but she has pictures of her in
croatia did you go to have you been to
Burma not the same place just got you
anyway shiny coins how come they just
look like quarters well if that is so
cool man I just want one I know it's
crazy but they have not concluded the
exact time of when this was created she
got the coins all [ __ ] the oldest [ __ ]
yeah that's all they got right now they
find matching Roman payphones yeah did
they find pay phones yes old there's a
big slip that means there's some Roman
drug lord the romans featherbrain
when I heard he did why would you be
bragging about me wanting to shut you
out okay friends you're gonna be goals
big slip day day what you need also
there's like a Roman drug lord that's
missing his money so it's gotta be
someone who was rich and they were
burying it and hiding it yeah well the
current theory is that because of the
fact that they don't know exactly what
time frame has happened they're assuming
that this is the Roman Empire stashing
away some money because of times of war
so they were that's what they're
assuming so we don't know for sure yet
but it's just kind of interesting
saving money yeah yeah how was it
discovered it was in a park when they
when workers were digging and digging in
ditches and that's when these these were
these pots were discovered a park where
it's called Zeldin
Park so we heard of it well that helps
yeah thank you thank you so modest it's
been okay thank you thank when you go to
these like ancient places or palaces or
whatever do you ever just touch the
marble again well I want to channel my
inner [ __ ] royal self that's
literally what I do every time I go to a
really ancient landmark yeah oh we went
to the Arc de Triomphe I had to touch it
we could each peel
did you [ __ ] Time Warp like a
[ __ ] did you feel I'm sacred
yes this is ancient and then you saw the
people suffered from the blackest [ __ ]
yeah I thought she'd like [ __ ] put
herself in the situation which is like I
tried with my imagination miss we close
at 5:30
ma'am you've been here two hours use
your hand off of that thing upstairs
downstairs downstairs is open always so
everywhere like there's been ancient
civilizations you walk around in your
life it's wild right no I think about
that when I go home California normal
yeah we go home it's the Chumash Indians
so it's like a brand-new build right so
like in our current home too like every
time I go and I visit yeah I'm like whoa
this used to be a like different kind of
building not a residential building but
then even further back I'm pretty sure
there were settlements where people
lived on this to mush it's the Chumash
right here where Jay King is is built I
guarantee you people this was murder
each other guarantee guarantee yeah I
was a Paiute it was a fucked-up time
that's why everyone hate loves to hate
on this time and like go on Twitter to
be like well oh my god you're so [ __ ]
up I can't believe you said that well we
try try you it was the Paiute but you
know that too much there too much the
California to Marsh tribe women too too
much no he was an Angelina so it was the
San Gabriels it was the same cable you
see they lost
I don't care that's the point right
is that [ __ ] up [ __ ] happen everywhere
everything around here in different ways
well especially in different countries
like Libya whoa yeah we were we were yet
yeah but no compared to here I'm like
thank you very much I'll take this I was
just talking about carjackings and [ __ ]
here but you did be announced but I was
thinking a slave markets but yeah I miss
how we transition to modern time because
I was still focused on the tomash area
tell us about I made a mistake
that's why the beach yes it's the
Gabrielle and I was here because we're
in the San Gabriel Valley it's the
Gabrielle Ino Indians I was taking a
Syrian Libya sorry in high school
well you know capilene oh sure versus
Gabrielle Ino Oh
oh no we weren't that good but
everywhere you go in the world
there's destruction but there's also
they cleaned that [ __ ] up yeah
because especially Olympic sites my mom
took a picture of that like they have
this building in Hiroshima where they
blew it up with the [ __ ] atomic bomb
right so but then those like this one
standing building that they keep there
but the whole place is like all cleaned
up and it's all modern nation there was
so much blood on the [ __ ] yeah it's
crazy like this because there's an old
photo and she's all like she's all
taking a picture with a bit of these
heels a lot of people died here oh yeah
and it's like dude what is it what kind
of key changes a cellar parotia right
that's what I want
we went to concentration camps and I can
get like I can vouch that there was no
much still there well that's good that
will be kind of weird
I know it's come on yeah that would be
really weird we did do a selfie but I
did do one of me standing there to just
brag to you guys that I was actually
there but I wasn't smiling I mean
sharing with you take a selfie no I
didn't act either I just stood there you
could kind of feel the doubts of the
lawyer what did Germany is like that you
could feel the video you can feel it yes
went down where'd you go in Jeremy that
felt all sad no country in the heart of
it dude I was in [ __ ] Oktoberfest
know the cat oh yes thank you
Oh Frank foot no I was [ __ ] beer at
Oktoberfest everyone's having a blast
he's like this is sad it was like that
yeah I was in Berlin and I was there to
see my brother who was actually
stationed an Air Force Base there the US
air force base that we took as part of
our spoils of war but yeah it was weird
we landed there's this [ __ ] heavy
energy and then you also look at the
same pictures like I'm seeing the same
sights as the pictures in my book or
Nazis walked and all that kind of [ __ ]
pretty weird yeah so there's a heaviness
covering I would love to say I don't
even think I know what I would do with
it
if I found treasure out of Park for sure
I'm not reporting there's no way I'm
gonna take that [ __ ] home figure out a
list
take it stars I'm thinking the Pawn
Stars I might yeah I found these old
doubloons at my grandpa's pool they
could figure out what is so smart I'm
again of course it's got water damage my
grandpa's pool you know took good care
so smarts if they do all the research
where you'll be [ __ ] all are good
they're so good at negotiating they
always take half of your money yeah this
is worth around $500,000 I need 20 I got
a [ __ ] whole building here I gotta
you know I gotta take care of this [ __ ]
know this number mommies they always
told me to be the expert no he's
literally part of the programming G yeah
G it just felt right do you see but
don't you listen listen it's 20/20 I
don't if it's my clown GM I love it I
receive Aleppo but our yeah that's not
the kind of treasure I was picturing in
my mind I look at it it's rusted copper
or whatever I'm like actually copper
well you thought it was gonna be gold
cuz you know how cop would change its
color over time it turns into that blue
[ __ ] so if I were to find this don't
share it with you don't give you a
cut-off weights copper and bronze the
same no right oh okay it's bronze did
you really did you really think that
usually copper dead listen I
I'm just honestly asking I did okay and
that's fine
that could be off-camera by the way I
don't even care you can cut that I'm
just genuine asking have you heard of
the Bronze Age
yeah because there's the Stone Age and
then the question see we should leave
that I don't mind nobody is in bronze
like an Iron Age it's all it's all like
a rose gold ish yeah it's third place
it's third place it is third place for
sure which was valued more bronze bronze
oh no you know what actually in America
copper really yeah yeah hey you know
yeah cuz meth heads are trying to get
copper from railroads and for
okay option why is it that every single
poor community all over the world want
to steal copper it could be because it's
conductive it's very hyper so they sell
it Dave
they sell it yeah for good money what
like is it sturdy enough till I use for
like building in copper yeah you can
melt it down in user for turbo pennies
are made out of copper and pennies are
only one city no they're not there
they're made of a very minimal amount of
time what the heck yeah
I don't believe [ __ ] holy [ __ ] do you
look at my [ __ ] I feel like bronze is
copper and iron put together but I
forgot yeah but copper is copper yeah
coppers its own element bronze ffensive
right now bronze is an alloy consisting
primarily of copper copper not only with
about 12 to 12.5 percent tin and I'll
attend with an addition of other metals
such as aluminum mag manganese magnesium
manganese that's what is that salt
manganese magma is a different kind of
agent Meaghan SC all right well we
learned nothing's tip tip tip tip copper
versus what you just Google covers
Meaghan either no no it'll be like shut
up copper you're gonna get you see
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]